as an entire nation buries its head and
sad the idea has swept the nation but
where will we find enough sand for
everyone now there are a lot of weird
ideas floating around out there to do
with the coronavirus depending on which
dark corner of the internet you read
apparently it's anything from a liberal
hoax to 5g activated chemtrails smart
dust more on that one later but well
most people are filming for anything
quite that ridiculous what is driving me
nuts
are these bad arguments I keep hearing
that kind of cloak themselves in rubbish
data and shoddy logic in order to sound
reasonable and these arguments are
dangerous because people are falling for
them and these can have some very real
and severe consequences so may I present
to you the seven worst coronavirus
arguments I mean sure I get how 1% at
first glance doesn't sound that bad and
I mean if we could picture this as some
kind of creepy hovered 19 wheel of
fortune then yes the chances of you
getting that unlucky deaths pin are very
unlikely but well I think most people
don't realize is how this risk stacks up
to other things that we consider
typically dangerous 1% is the same
fatality rate as a full lifetime's worth
of driving yet think about how much
money and effort society is spent on
seatbelts and speed limits and speed
cameras and so on trying to reduce that
risk but let's go back to our wheel now
people seem to be forgetting other bad
outcomes like the wrists on permanent
lung damage or a long hospital visit now
let's
we will be fine but now it's time to
pass on the wheel to to your closest
people thank you for playing well whilst
I checked all people are still people
and who knows maybe you even know an
older person you don't wish them 10
percent or greater chance of death on
oh yes so next we have this one from the
self defeatism camp I mean at first
glance I get why this seems so wise and
baby Yoder ish I mean why worry about
what you can't control except for
there's probably some kind of agency we
have over this like presumably these
people agree that there's some
difference between safe staying home
right now and jumping on a plane to
Rouen and getting it back Suppan
but even if it is already too late there
are still things that we can do right
now to reduce how bad it's gonna be our
actions over the next few weeks can
decide whether it's a long but
manageable wave that hits hospitals or
we get hit by some hellish tsunami that
collapses medical infrastructure and
pushes the risk of death up for everyone
[Music]
so yes a similar starting point to the
one before but with more of a em
doomsayer flair these are the folks who
also think is too late but also think
it's the end of everything that we hold
dear
even the mind-blowing ly horrible
Spanish flu of 1918 which infected one
in every three people on earth and had a
higher death rate still only put a
temporary halt on economic growth and
society quickly rebounded plus medicine
has improved quite a lot
so big city oh now this one mmm drives
me mad because it doesn't actually say
anything useful the word panic is
completely subjective like to some
people
it literally means crying and rocking in
the fetal position in the corner and to
others it's how they would describe
anyone who's expending any extra energy
trying to reduce their coronavirus risk
at all so when you do hear someone
making this kind of statement make sure
to ask them which specific actions
qualify as panic according to the
detailed cost-benefit analysis they must
surely have done because of course no
one would ever just say this kind of
thing to virtue signal some kind of
stoic superiority yes indeed the numbers
in China are slowing down and quite
spectacularly I might add I mean
honestly it's a miracle who could
possibly imagine what would cause such a
dramatic drop in new cases mr. C I
understand why the idea of having to do
any kind of draconian quarantine
measures sounds terrible but we've seen
that it clearly works so why people B
then try and argue that we don't need to
do them because they worked elsewhere
when it's clearly spreading so there was
this thing called time and we don't only
care about previous time we also care
about upcoming time in what is known as
the future but seriously this
coronavirus is brand-new whereas flu has
been around forever and it's already
endemic around the world so it's really
unfair to compare those two numbers so
far I wanna get the exponential growth
is very counterintuitive and can really
make us underestimate just how fast
these numbers can grow the reason why
this argument made my number-one spot is
because it's as absurd as if you're
walking down the street
you notice a boom drop out of a plane
over your head like guys quick your
friends like oh shut up your whining
it's not killed anyone yet so there you
have it these are the seven worst
arguments I've heard and it's very
important we count to these when we hear
them because coronavirus is kind of a
self unfulfilled prophecy the more we
downplay it the worse it'll get
but if we take it seriously we can
actually beat it so yeah I guess we
really do just have to do this annoying
social distancing thing right now
because it is the only weapon we have to
fight against this damn virus and it's
kind of weird that the most social thing
we can be doing is to stay the hell away
from each other
and on that note time to revisit that 5d
chemtrail story I came across on very
dark spiral event on Facebook don't ask
about it that sounded - um - bring it to
life a little more which is I guess what
happens when you don't leave your house
for a week the Chinese were all given
mandatory vaccines last fall this
vaccine contained replicating digitised
controllable RNA which were activated by
60 gigahertz five millimeter 5g waves
that were just turned on in Wuhan the
smartest everyone on the globe has been
inhaling through chemtrails that's why
when they save someone can be cured the
virus can be digitally reactivated at
any time and the person can literally
drop dead the Diamond Princess cruise
ship was specifically equipped with 60
gigahertz 5g it's basically remote
assassination Americans are currently
breathing in this smart to us through
chemtrails think of it like this at the
combination of vaccines chemtrails smart
dust and 5g and your body becomes
internally digitized and can be remotely
controlled a person's organ functions
can be stopped remotely if one thing's
not lookin tired
whoo-hah
strong ID 2020 the elite call this 60
gigahertz millimeter 5g wave of the V
wave to mock us
Trump has created a space force in part
to combat this weaponized technology we
need to Vemma be reject the attempted
mandatory vaccine issue because our
lives depend on it